her majesty's government's priority
is to grow and strengthen the economy
and help ease the cost of living for
families
her majesty's government will level up
opportunity in all parts of the country
and support more people into work
our majesty's ministers
will continue to support the police
to make the streets safer
and fund the national health service to
reduce the kovid backlogs
in these challenging times
her majesty's government
will play a leading role
in defending democracy and freedom
across the world
including continuing to support
the people of ukraine
her majesty's government will drive
economic growth
to improve living standards
and fund sustainable investment
in public services
this will be underpinned
by a responsible approach
to the public finances
reducing debt
while reforming
and cutting taxes
her majesty's ministers
will support the bank of england
to return inflation to its target
a bill will be brought forward
to drive local growth
empowering local leaders
to regenerate their areas
and ensuring everyone can share in the
united kingdom's success
the planning system will be reformed
to give residents more involvement in
local development
their majesty's government will improve
transport
across the united kingdom
delivering safer
cleaner
services
and enabling more innovations
legislation will be introduced
to modernize rail services
and improve reliability for passengers
i manage these ministers will bring
forward
an energy bill to deliver the transition
to cheaper cleaner
and more secure energy
this will build on the success of the
cop 26 summit
in glasgow last year
draft legislation
to promote competition
strengthen consumer rights
and protect households and businesses
will be published
measures will also be published to
create new competition rules for digital
markets
and the largest digital firms
her majesty's government will establish
the uk infrastructure bank
in legislation
with objectives to support economic
growth
and the delivery of net zero
reforms to education
will help every child fulfill their
potential
wherever they live raising standards and
improving the quality of schools
and higher education
her majesty's ministers will publish
draft legislation
to reform the mental health act
her majesty's government will continue
to seize the opportunities
of the united kingdom's departure from
the european union
to support economic growth
regulations on businesses will be
repealed and reformed
a bill will enable law inherited from
the european union
to be more easily amended
public sector procurement
will be simplified to provide new
opportunities for small businesses
new legislation will strengthen the
united kingdom's financial services
industry
ensuring that he continues to act in the
interest of all people
and communities
the united kingdom's data protection
regime
will be reformed
her majesty's government will continue
to champion international trade
delivering jobs across the country
and growing the economy
legislation will be introduced
to enable the implementation
of the united kingdom's first new
free trade agreements since leaving the
european union
her majesty's ministers
will encourage agricultural
and scientific innovation at home
legislation will unlock the potential of
new technologies
to promote sustainable and efficient
farming and food production
her majesty's government will protect
the integrity of the united kingdom's
borders
and ensure the safety of its people
her majesty's ministers will take action
to prevent dangerous and illegal channel
crossings
and tackle the criminal gangs who profit
from facilitating them
legislation will be introduced to ensure
the police have the powers to make the
streets safer
a bill will be brought forward to
further strengthen powers to tackle
illicit finance
reduce economic crime
and help businesses grow
measures will be introduced to support
the security services and help them
protect the united kingdom
her majesty's government will lead the
way
in championing security around the world
it will continue to invest in her
majesty's gallant armed forces
her majesty's ministers will work
closely with international partners to
maintain a united nato
and address the most pressing global
security challenges
the continued success and integrity of
the whole of the united kingdom is of
paramount importance to her majesty's
government
including the internal economic bonds
between all of its parts
her majesty's government will prioritize
support
for the belfast good friday agreement
and its institutions
including through legislation to address
the legacy of the past
her majesty's government will ensure the
constitution is defended
her majesty's ministers will restore the
balance of power
between the legislature and the courts
by introducing a bill of rights
legislation will prevent public bodies
engaging in boycotts
that undermine community cohesion
her majesty's government will introduce
legislation
to improve the regulation of social
housing to strengthen the rights of
tenants
and ensure better quality safer homes
legislation will also be introduced to
ban conversion therapy
proposals will be published to establish
an independent regulator
of english football
in this year of the platinum jubilee
her majesty looks forward to the
celebrations
taking place across the united kingdom
and throughout the commonwealth
and to the commonwealth games in
birmingham this summer
members of the house of commons
estimates for the public services will
be laid before you
my lords
and members of the house of commons
other measures will be laid before you
her majesty prays that the blessing of
almighty god
may rest upon your councils